franke du hast nähere informationen zu
dieser schockierenden meldung
ja genau ich stehe jetzt hier vor dem
uniklinikum in essen
man kann das interview sehen ich drehe
ich arbeitsprozess ist genau dieser
bereich der hinter mir hinten erleuchtet
ist die fenster dort ist diese
intensivstationen die nur für
komapatienten vorgesehen ist dann muss
auch ganz kurz wissen die uniklinik
essen ist sehr führen gerade in
nordrhein westfalen die meisten der
koma-patientin wir noch keine angaben
und es ist auch froh dass sogar
patienten ausland und italien
eingeflogen
ja und jetzt ist sie das schreckliche
vorraum medizinern hier in der klinik
und fehlgeburt und dann haben selbst die
staatsanwaltschaft informiert dass der
verdacht besteht dass dieser oberarzt 44
jahre alt zwei patienten am 13 und 17
uhr immer so sagt sie dass bereits
medikamente verabreicht haben soll so
die staatsanwaltschaft ihn schnell zum
tode geführt hat in seiner vernehmung
als er dann zur polizei musste ausgesagt
er habe das leid der patienten und der
angehörigen mildern wollen die patienten
sagt eigentlich zu retten gewesen und
wir hören ja immer wieder gerade bei
schweren verläufen sei es das gefühl man
würde lebendig ertrinken und bei vollem
bewusstsein
das kann natürlich ein punkt gewesen das
aber das ist natürlich nicht möglich
kann ja nicht als arzt und patienten
spritzen gerade weil die beiden
patienten 47 und 50 jahre alt waren das
muss man auch wissen wir waren also noch
relativ jung
warum der mediziner jetzt glaubt das ist
ihnen nicht mehr zu helfen müssen jetzt
auch produktionen klären
außerdem prüft die polizei natürlich der
mediziner seit februar dieses jahres
hier an dem krankenhaus in essen gibt es
möglicherweise noch weitere fälle
es wird jetzt geprüft ob er patienten
versorgt werde ihr verstorben sind und
was man auch noch wissen muss er hat die
angehörigen dieser beiden patienten noch
bevor das medikament verabreicht hat das
bankenhaus gibt keine hoffnung mehr es
geht mit angehörigen zu ende
und hat man wenn die angehörigen dann da
gewesen sind um abschied zu nehmen dann
eben diese patienten mit einem
medikament getötet
und die ermittlungen auf wie optionen
laufen umsetzt abwarten was am ende
rauskommt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren